[Music]
female genital mutilation is still
carried out in a number of religious and
traditional cultures usually to control
the girls sexuality and as a
precondition for marriage the practice
is painful and it does significant harm
to the victim and it's performed mostly
on young girls now what's more it's been
illegal in the UK for decades and
according to Britain's National Health
Service almost 7,000 women and girls
who'd undergone the surgery received
medical treatment in 2018 and there are
around 1,500 cases every three months in
the UK we spoke to the executive
director of forward UK that's the
foundation for women's health research
and development she says that the
practice causes lifelong problems for
victims the reality is that FGM is a
human rights violation MGM causes harm
FGM also affects the health and
well-being of women and girls
a number of people are going through a
lot of emotional trauma but I'm not able
to when we speak to some of the women
that we work with women will tell you
that they have flashbacks when they see
knives or DC blades and these are the
things that are part of issues that have
actually been suppressed in their mind
for a very long time there is also the
element of those who do have
psychosexual problems as a result of
going through female genital mutilation
we do know that the worst cases of
post-traumatic stress disorder and it's
something that we are forward we are
increasingly seeing we through our work
with community women a lot of the
supports we see in women after training
they request to have additional support
particularly on emotional well-being
you